you were around when it was the Cuba
crisis in 62.
do you have a memory of that crisis or
not at all I mean I I was 14 years old
but I I do have a memory of that crisis
and I do have a sense of how much danger
the world was in
and I also do have a feeling that in
2022 we are coming close to 1962. I was
five years old when at the time of the
Cuban Missile Crisis but I do remember
quite vividly the fear of people at that
time the fear of Armageddon we you know
we would we took absolutely seriously
the possibility that this was the end
and a memory that I have that had a
profound influence on me personally was
watching the television and the Great
British philosopher Bertrand Russell was
on television
um he had given up philosophy in order
to campaign against nuclear weapons
and he he'd started a thing called the
committee of a hundred which took the
work of the uh CND the campaign for
nuclear disarmament and working towards
the same ends but adopting different
means he encouraged Civil Disobedience
and I remember him on the television on
the on on the streets of Whitehall
encouraging a mass sit down against the
law and a reporter asked him you know
Lord Russell why are you doing this and
Russell who had this extraordinary voice
nobody has spoken English like Russell
since the 18th century
um Russell said well
if the policies of the present
governments are to are are to be
continued they will inevitably result in
the complete annihilation of humankind
he said and some of us think that might
be rather a pity
and this is uh largely because of that
you know a few years later I I joined
the uh CND and and uh campaigned for
nuclear disarmament uh first of all I
think that Putin's uh uh trying to scare
people
uh in my opinion this is what it's all
about he's uh he wants to push back and
to deter
uh NATO countries and others from
continuing to support Ukraine and so if
he scares people then they will back
call so I think that's that's the real
motivation how much he's really thought
about it I don't know the dangerous part
of this is that it appears that the
Russian military
with whatever support and backing or
instigation they have from their
political leaders have this nuclear
calculation in their War fighting ideas
so at what point they may decide that
they
ought to do this I have no idea
that's the danger to me there is not
going to be a general exchange nuclear
exchange between Russia and the West
because the Terence does work I was one
of the officials who
Declassified Warsaw parked documents I
would Declassified the Polish part we
were the second Army of the Warsaw Pact
for a general invasion of Western Europe
and Soviet forces were going to New
Germany they were going to New Denmark
and they were new going to New Holland
but not France and the UK guess why
because France in the UK are nuclear
pies deterrence Works Putin is not going
to Nuke us what the danger is that he
might nuke a country that voluntarily
gave up its nuclear weapons Ukraine and
and and it's a much harder question uh
to ask you know how to prevent that it's
actually quite easy
the best way to prevent a nuclear war
over Ukraine is for Russia not to start
it
nobody else will do it and nobody else
is threatening it
now how do we deter Putin from attacking
a non-nuclear state that's the real
issue